I think I know what the formula is for
our Channel and every person's channel
is going to be different when I am doing
something that is contrarian or highly
polarizing you could be for it you could
be against it doesn't matter when I'm
doing something that feels like it's a
real um some emotion like this is
reality TV I'm arguing with a potential
client and we're going through stuff
that you're going to be on one side of
the other and it stirs up all kinds of
emotions and then there's a piece of
value that's baked into that that seems
to be the winning formula for any video
that pops for us that's a that's a
formula though that I do think applies
to almost any Niche and any platform the
polarizing one is a big one if it could
be triggering and again the goal would
be I think to do that ethically is
you're not like sitting down to just
make something up you're digging deep
into self-awareness of what is your True
Values principles convictions um and
then not being afraid to share those
also a something that hurts I think
social media virality is
hedging and one of the things that helps
it is by stating something in an
absolute I think what we have to
remember is that even truth is held in
tension that there could be two sides
this is a mistake for me because when I
do think about every audience I like to
hedge that's not what triggers and goes
viral what goes viral is by making a
statement what we're afraid of is people
then go yeah but what about the other
side and you could say well this was a
16sec short so it's not that I'm saying
there's not another side and this was
actually this a power principle for
anybody who made it this long in the
podcast this is worth I remember I
remember going to traffic and conversion
Summit opening session Ryan dice
actually spoke about five elements of
creating movements and five elements of
of uh you essentially should create a
mve movement even a cult and that's a
strong word but if you look at Jim
Collins built to last good organizations
good teams have cult-like elements all
that to say was uh one of those things
was you said that the greatest movement
leaders speaking absolutes and he
mentioned characters like Grant Cardone
and Gary Vee you often times hear Gary
Vee say I remember back in 2011 I went
to a live talk and he said my friends
if you are not using search.twitter.com
daily you will not be in
business five years from
now
okay there could be no further false
statement from the truth like there's
first of all probably everybody in that
room is probably still in business five
years from now none of them went home
and you search.
twitter.com everybody could probably get
away from not never using Twitter search
strategically or whatever but his
conviction and the point he's trying to
make now me also too as a background in
PR Communications I was a director of
communication at a church I always want
to like tell every side like if you're
not using search unless you're this or
maybe it's not true for every industry
it's not true so all that to just go a
little bit deeper on that polarizing
thing I think that if you're listening
to this sometimes you just might be
afraid to put something out there or you
if you are like me and you're like yeah
but yeah but what about this or what and
by the way add on top of that Council
culture add on top of that you're
putting something on the internet but
how could you possibly speak to every
different background um economic
background you know cultural background
and you're like well in certain context
this could be offensive you got to be
willing to push P all the greats are
willing to push past that they're not
they're they're and if we're defining
Greatness by
reach they're not afraid of being
misunderstood they're not afraid of
triggering people they're not afraid and
this is not the I think the myth is a
lot of us like to be liked and we like
to be um perceived as kind we don't want
we don't want to offend anybody and
listen all of these things can coexist
at the same time like that could all be
true about you but if you want the
growth and the reach you got to put it
out there and be okay with somebody
saying yeah but what about the
alternative you're like well this's is
an entire video podcast like this was
just the short of it like I break down
the other side or or there's more to it
or for you to assume or color in you
leave little mystery like you're leaving
it yeah but what if you got to be okay
with the 10 WH ifs and make the
statement and that was one of the
attributes was that that these movement
leaders and you could argue on social
media these viral videos because it's
it's really getting a lot of reach is
it's it's it's polarizing you're stating
something you're making a conviction
there's emotional tension there arguably
triggering but Chris knowing you you're
doing this from a place of Integrity
your experience love for the audience
and I'm sure we could look in the
comments and see a lot of people that
are upset and offended potentially uh as
you talk about how much you should pay a
lot of people I can never charge that
month why would you tell people you know
uh oh yes this all that kind of stuff
and those are your most feuded videos
you're listening to this right now there
is Untold growth for your business your
personal brand your
reach on the other side of you giving up
the fear of other people's opinions the
need to be liked the need to please
everyone and the need to avoid offending
anyone you never could anyways but you
got to crank up that tolerance for that
and there's a lot of growth on the other
side when you start putting out powerful
messaging that you believe in on YouTube
and social media Sean before we get out
of here I just want to say a couple
things in reaction to what you just
said the criticism of people that the
criticism about social media people
Lobby against me and just social media
in general is that we're not having
these Nuance thorough analysis
conversations and there's a time in
place for that but what we have to do is
we have to stop someone to get them pay
attention long enough so they can learn
something they can take action on and
improve their lives that day and I find
that when I try to phrase something
that's so nuanced it just loses all the
bite and the punch it's like it's been
watered down and so I need to say in a
way that someone who needs to hear this
today in this moment can hear it so I
said recently
theory is lonely it loves action don't
keep them apart that is not a nuanced
statement I'm clearly have an opinion
and a point of view to this and that's
the post that people are like well let's
reshare this let's uh and that's what
happens so but if you were to sit there
and give a dissertation on that people
would yawn they're going to move on to
the next thing we're now whether you
like it or not the attention span has
been so reduced if you can't capture
them in that hook that headline the
thumb nail they're not going to watch
the video in the first minute of the
video if you can't keep them they're out
and so you have to learn The Art of
Storytelling and this kind of the Jenga
effect which is I kind of know what's
going to happen but I can't turn away
you're going to keep pulling apart until
it looks like it's going to fall apart
and then it's done if you enjoyed this
podcast and are ready for some deep dive
YouTube strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my 1H
hour OnDemand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com